[Musique]
j'ai grandi dans le mythe du self made
man
cette croyance qui dit que tout homme
peut réussir et grâce à son mérite
personnel en partant de rien ou alors de
peu que la méritocratie était la seule
façon de s'épanouir dans la vie pour
réussir il fallait cultiver l'excellence
et être le meilleur
j'ai toujours été un élève dans la
moyenne haute
mais j'étais ce genre d'élève qui lors
des travaux de groupe n'était jamais
satisfait du travail de mes camarades et
je me sentais tout le temps obligé de
repasser derrière eux je leur posais
alors uniquement sur les résultats
considérant la vie comme une oeuvre qui
doit être achevé à coups d'objectif en
oubliant les étapes essentielles à sa
construction
j'ai appris que toujours vouloir être le
meilleur était très mauvais lorsque j'ai
mis 100 % de mon temps libre à la
création de mon entreprise
au début l'expérience est excitante
je pouvais mettre en pratique tout ce
que j'avais vu en cours et même plus
encore mais très vite il y avait un
problème
je me sentais tout temps sollicité je
n'avais plus une minute à moi c'est
alors que j'ai pris conscience de mon
erreur j'arrive à pas seul tout
simplement parce que mon temps personnel
est limité chaque jour je dois
travailler sur mon projet mais je vais
aussi manger dormir voir mes amis voir
ma famille et puis me retrouver seule
c'est important d'être sale parfois
en travaillant sur mon projet je me suis
rendu compte que je n'avais que 24
heures dans ma journée est donc 24
heures maximum a accordé à mon projet
c'est le temps personnel ce temps peut
être utilisé de différentes façons
l'acquisition de connaissances
le networking le travail sur son coeur
de métier le développement personnel
sans oublier le temps indispensable qui
n'est pas consacré au projet mais 24
heures dans une journée
si finalement assez peu pour construire
un projet impactant et durable alors je
me suis posé une question où peut-on
aller chercher le temps pour faire
grandir nos projets en me posant cette
question j'ai tout de suite pensé aux
associations en france il ya plus d'un
point 3 million d'associations
rassemblant plus de 16 millions de
personnes
chaque membre partagent une vision et un
engagement commun qui leur permettre de
s'investir quelques heures de façon
bénévole en 2017
le budget cumulé des associations en
france était de 85 milliards d'euros 85
milliards vous vous rendez compte
c'est l'équivalent de 25 porte-avions ou
400 avions airbus
alors j'ai réalisé une chose accomplir
de petites actions collectivement
multiplient la valeur de notre temps ce
temps qui nous est donnée par les
personnes enthousiasmées par nos idées
nos projets ou touchés par nos actions
et bien moi je vais donner un nom c'est
le temps d'engagement collectif le temps
d'engagement collectif
c'est la somme totale du temps qui a été
accumulée par toutes les personnes qui
nous ont aidés pour prendre projet si on
veut construire quelque chose de plus
grand que soi il nécessaire de faire
appel aux autres et de co construire
ensemble le temps d'engagement collectif
il est potentiellement infinis il est
seulement limitées au nombre et à la
nature des relations que nous
entretenons avec nos semblables
je vous donne un exemple très rapide
si on devait compter tout le temps passé
par les joueurs de world of warcraft le
jeu en ligne depuis sa création
savez-vous ce qu'on obtiendrait 6
millions d'années en tout c'est bien 6
millions d'années qui ont été passées
par les joueurs sur ce jeu si on devait
cumuler tous temps et le ramener à une
seule ligne temporelle puis remonter
dans le temps l'humanité ressemblerait à
ça
alors je me suis fait une raison
le mythe du self made man est mort et
enterré
en fait il a jamais existé
il convenait bien à l'époque des
premiers pionniers américains pour
raconter l'histoire de ceux qui ont bâti
des empires à la force de leurs bras
dans un pays où tout était à créer mais
aujourd'hui nous savons que les
entrepreneurs ne peuvent pas à réussir
seul c'est l'engagement de leur
communauté et de leur réseau qui fera la
différence
le futur de l'entrepreneuriat sera plus
humanisé et collaboratif chaque individu
entretien un parcours de revin un tissu
de relations pardon solidaire de son
parcours et qui lui ont permis d'arriver
jusqu'ici
je vais maintenant vous raconter deux
histoires la première histoire se
déroule en février 2010 est mélanie sega
une jeune fille trisomique de 21 ans
rêve
comme chaque soir de présenter la météo
à la télévision tout son entourage sait
pertinemment qu'aucune chaîne de
télévision lui donnera une chance
d'apparaître à l'écran
celle ci préférant recycler d'anciens
mannequin ou lancé la carrière de jeunes
acteurs une mélanie elle décourage pas
pour autant
et pour accomplir son rêve elle décide
de créer une page facebook sur cette
page
elle lance un défi si ma page atteint
100 me like
alors vous me ferez présentatrice météo
pour un soir
devinez la suite quarante huit heures
après le lancement de sa page facebook
cent vingt mille personnes avaient
rejoint sa communauté
cinq jours après le lancement de sa page
à page facebook avait déjà plus de deux
mille deux cent cinquante mille mention
j'aime à son actif inimaginable
parmi les 250 mille personnes ayant vu
la page de mélanie il y avait deux
chaînes de télévision bfm tv et france 2
toutes deux lui ont offert la
possibilité de présenter la météo sur
leur chaîne
en l'espace d'une semaine mélanie est
passé de rêve impossible dans sa chambre
à devoir choisir sur quelle chaîne
elle avait présenté la météo
finalement mélanie choisi france 2 et
deux semaines plus tard le 14 mars 2017
mélanie réalise en rêve si on fait
tulle 250000 like mettant en moyenne
trente secondes c'est 21 mille heures
d'engagement soit environ 13 ans à temps
complet c'est l'exemple même d'un projet
qui a été réalisé grâce à de petites
actions cumulé qui n'aurait jamais pu se
faire tout seul
aujourd'hui mélanie travaille toujours
dans la même entreprise dette par le
travail mais avec quelque chose en plus
elle partage avec 250 mille autres
personnes
le sentiment que le temps d'engagement
collectif est la solution pour aider les
autres
la deuxième histoire elle se déroule en
mai 2008
en mai 2008 des chercheurs de
l'université de washington aux etats
unis cherchent depuis dix ans à
synthétiser une nouvelle protéine cette
protéine
elle est essentielle dans la lutte
contre la propagation du virus du sida
voyons tous leurs efforts pendant dix
ans s'avérer vains ils décident de
s'associer aux départements
informatiques pour créer un jeu vidéo
dans ce jeu vidéo appelé foldit
les joueurs doivent combattre le virus
du sida en reconstituant des protéines
le jeu de nos joueurs les éléments
essentiels pour recréer des protéines en
3d et leur permet de les triturer dans
tous les sens avec les règles de la
chimie moléculaire comme seule limite
les joueurs travaillent en équipes lors
but reconstituer une structure
s'approche le plus possible de la forme
finale de la protéine ces modèles sont
ensuite présentés à des scientifiques
pour pouvoir les tester en laboratoire
et voir si ça correspond vraiment à la
protéine recherché
à son lancement soixante mille personnes
se sont mis à jouer régulièrement aux et
trois semaines plus tard les joueurs ont
réussi à synthétiser la protéine tant
recherchée par les scientifiques
en l'espace de trois semaines les
joueurs de foldit ont réussi là où la
recherche scientifique avait échoué
pendant dix ans saisissant n'est ce pas
quand j'ai entendu ces histoires pour la
première fois je n'en revenais pas c'est
comme si grâce à internet et au
développement des sciences
participatives on pouvait littéralement
tout faire on peut même aider la nasa à
chercher des signaux extraterrestres
rien qu'en leur partageant une petite
partie de la puissance de calcul de nos
ordinateurs à distance selon les projets
et les causes qui vous porte
vous pouvez investir un petit peu de
votre temps personnel et vous engagez
collectivement avec une action aussi
simple qu'un like ou que la
participation à un jeu peu importe le
projet les idées ou les actions si vous
les faites ensemble ou généré un impact
positif
alors la prochaine fois qu'un ami vous
demandera de prendre un petit peu de
temps pour l'aider dans son projet peu
importe l'action prenait conscience de
l'impact que ça pourra avoir
- ch
toujours fasciné par ce temps
d'engagement collectif
tiens par exemple sur gulli depuis 2014
ces cent trente mille personnes qui ont
donné plus de deux millions de repas
via le programme alimentaire mondial
rien qu'en regardant des publicités de
20 secondes
ça représente 11 mille deux cents heures
d'engagement à peine plus de cinq
minutes par personne
alors voyons toutes ces effervescence
bah moi aussi j'ai eu envie de m'engager
et donc j'ai pris une décision celle de
regarder au moins une fois par jour une
vidéo publicitaire sur gulli pour
contribuer moi aussi à cet effort
collectif
aujourd'hui c'est un jour un petit peu
particulier pour moi un petit peu
symbolique car je viens d'atteindre les
100 repas distribués merci
[Applaudissements]